Speaker 1: And while we're
on the subject of the Trumps,
Donald Trump did an interview this week with
Tucker Carlson, the man who in text messages
revealed during the Dominion lawsuit, said
he wished Trump would go away. He was looking
forward to never having to talk about him again.
Hates him with a passion and then sat down like a
little sad puppy to interview Donald Trump and
gave him a shoulder to cry on. But it wasn't
Trump that was crying. It wasn't Tucker either,
because according to Donald Trump's interview,
it was actually the courthouse workers in New York
that were sobbing uncontrollably when poor old
Donald Trump was brought in for the arraignment.
Here is what Donald Trump said to Tucker.
They were incredible. When I went to the
courthouse, which is also a prison, in a sense,
I'm sorry, before I could even finish that
statement. Like what? It's also kind of like
a no, it's actually not like that's not
what a courthouse is. A courthouse is a
courthouse. It's which where you have trials.
It's where you have arraignments. It's where
you sometimes go to pay parking tickets. It's
not the prison. I'm sure they probably have
a holding cell there for people that are held
in contempt if there's not a local county jail
nearby. But a courthouse is not in and
of itself also a prison. So that's just
a weird statement and it's not even the
dumbest thing he said. So I'll continue.
They signed me in and I'll tell you, people
were crying. They were actually crying. He said,
It's just sobbing, just tears flowing like a
river. Throughout that Manhattan courthouse,
they had to put out wet floor signs because
the tears, I guess, were just overwhelming.
Nobody was crying. If there was any crying
taking place in that courtroom that day,
it was most likely tears of joy, tears of joy that
justice had finally caught up with Donald Trump,
tears of joy that this man was no longer to
get away with everything that he has been
accused of for years and years and years
and years. Tears of joy that maybe. Maybe.
This guy might finally get his comeuppance. But
even then, I don't even think they were crying
tears of joy. They were just people doing their
jobs like, it's just our job. But I will say,
if Donald Trump thinks these workers in Manhattan
love him. There is video where Donald Trump was,
you know, they were kind of holding the doors for
people. And then when it was Trump's turn to walk
through it, they just let it go and it almost hit
him in the face. So I don't exactly think those
workers were in love with you. Not to mention,
we're talking about a courthouse in Manhattan.
Donald Trump viewers universally disliked in
Manhattan. If this had been a courtroom in Texas,
yeah, you probably would have had some some
diehard Trump supporters in there crying for
you. Same thing if it was in Texas or Florida
or Alabama. Yeah, I believe that story then.
But see, that's the point, Donald. Like when
you're going to lie to people. And of course,
Tucker Carlson didn't push back at all because
he's a coward. But if you're going to lie to
people, you got to make the lie believable,
Donald. I mean, come on, you've done this
enough. You know how to play the game. Nobody is
going to believe that these courthouse workers
that other people have seen were crying that day.
There is nobody with tears in their eyes on video
or in any of the pictures. There is no one coming
out to corroborate your story. Tucker Carlson, if
he had a shred of dignity, would have pushed back
on this. But of course he doesn't. So he didn't.
But nobody in that courthouse
was sad, Donald. Except for you.
And I say that because you've talked a big
game attacking that judge before and after
your arraignment. But you were silent during the
arraignment. You said a total of about ten words,
most of them just one word at a time. Yes. No,
thank you. Not guilty. So when you actually had
the opportunity to stand up and tell that judge
what you thought, you didn't do it because you're
also a coward. So instead, you then go running
to your little buddy, Tucker Carlson, who again,
claims to hate you. You tell him a lie. He
doesn't push back. And nobody believed your story.